What did the 2010's add up to?
I spent the decade at Reason creating videos about the democratization of everything
and the declining power of society's gatekeepers.
Media theorist Marshall McLuhan, who coined the axiom, the medium is the message,
argued that history's prime mover isn't the great leader or great thinker,
but ever-changing communications technologies.
Everything that we prize in our Western world in matters of individualism, separatism,
a unique point of view, a private judgement, all those factors are highly favored by the printed word,
and not really favored by other forms.
As societies moved from oral traditions to written ones McLuhan argued
there was a cultural shift. Tribal groups who relied on face-to-face communication and mythology
morphed into more complex, less homogeneous societies.
Thanks to the written word and when the printing press standardized communications,
the distribution of literature created the very concept of a public,
bound together by common languages and texts. This set the stage for the rise of modern nation-states
and the Enlightenment. Millions of words across thousands of miles.
In the 1960s McLuhan identified our current epoch as the Electric Age
in which circuit based media gave rise to what he termed, the global village.
For the first time in history the entire world could follow a single event.
McLuhan predicted that this electric global village would undo both the national homogeneity
and personal individuality engendered by print, reviving our more fractured and tribal past.
We're re-tribalizing. Involuntarily we're getting rid of individualism.
We're more concerned with what the group knows, with feeling as it does, of acting with it.
And as the electric age has evolved into the digital age with its cheap limitless replicability,
this re-tribalization has accelerated in the 2010's,
which is why the past decade has both created opportunities and dangers
for the libertarian and liberal worldviews.
What we have already achieved
gives us hope the audacity to hope for
what we can and must achieve tomorrow
Barack Obama epitomized the best and
worst of the decade as a longshot
candidate he used new modes of
communication to route around and
eventually co-opted media gatekeepers
he built a cult of personality through
social media using inspiring rhetoric so
vague that people could project anything
onto his words what this country has
already done what free men and women can
achieve when imagination has joined a
common purpose the Obama White House
produced and distributed its own content
undermining the establishments ability
to define him photojournalists for
example were denied access to the
president's most intimate moments but
were free to publish the selective
imagery of the official White House
photographer the White House went to
create an identity for the President and
because they can distribute directly
through all these different channels
there's really not much downside to it
there's not much accountability Obama
wasn't the only one who understood new
media better than the gatekeepers
disruptive figures like Andrew Breitbart
I'm here coincidentally I just arrived
in James O'Keefe embarrassed the
establishment bringing down national
political organizations like ACORN and
Congressman Anthony Weiner and casting
doubt on media narratives about the
emerging Tea Party movement the same
dynamic was at play when teenage boys
were accused of harassing a Native
American elder at the Lincoln Memorial
until reasons own Ravi suave did a more
thorough analysis of the raw cell phone
footage when you're reporting something
that confirms all of your biases you
have to be really sure you have to
consider evidence that conflicts with
that Occupy Wall Street protestors
capitalized on the digital age to gain
widespread attention for their movement
and of course there's Edward Snowden who
carefully selected his own gatekeepers
to bring US government secrets out into
the open and then spoke directly to the
public to defend his actions over time
that awareness of wrongdoing sort of
builds up and you feel compelled to talk
about it DIY culture is hardly new but
the 2010 czar when journalists
governments and the public at large were
forced to take it serious
renegade gunsmith Cody Wilson created
not just the 3d printed gun but just as
importantly content about the 3d printed
gun if you only knew that terribly like
embarrassing vulnerable like physicality
of these things these objects would just
crumple and fall apart so the media
cannot help themselves if I can get
something 80% of the way they will take
it to its completion and then a bit
further than that Wilson also epitomized
the permissionless attitude that
accelerated in the 2010s by enabling his
customers to make firearms without the
involvement of the state we're trying to
push through facts on the ground that
change what the political reality is
independent of our institutions
hopefully one day it won't matter what
these men and women black robes say
because you just know that you can
download the air 15 from the internet
crank one out in your garage crank two
out in your garage or take DIY genetic
engineering kits pioneered by former
NASA biologists turned biohacking
entrepreneur Josiah Zener our people
dying and suffering needlessly because
all these committees and all these rules
and what happens if people just start
saying like fuck you I'm gonna do it
anyway and what if people start getting
cured Ross Ulbricht launched the first
but not last dark web drug market this
is about punishment and making him an
example and uber lyft an Airbnb
disrupted and undermined entrenched
industries with ubiquitous pocket
computers you cannot cope with vast
amounts of information in the old
fragmentary classified patterns you tend
to go looking for mythic and structural
forms in order to manage such complex
data and moving at very high speeds if
Obama mastered the use of new media to
control image and messaging Trump
exploited its tendency to discombobulate
and retry belies he probably will win
the presidency based just unskilled
cartoonist and writer Scott Adams
predicted a trump victory more than a
year before the election after observing
his persuasion tactics it's more of a
strategy than you imagined it is I've
said that if Trump wins it might change
how we see the world not just how we see
politics but how we see humans and how
humans are influenced and how little
reason has anything to do with
what we do political scientists will
debate the various reasons for Trump's
victory for years but with his
background in reality TV and mass
marketing there's little doubt he excels
at making himself heard by an American
public stretched thin by an increasingly
overwhelming flow of information
Trump's concepts and phrases stick in
our minds you are fake news something
going on and it's bad in Chicago it's a
wind chime about the Winchester foreign
actors capitalized on the declining
trust and institutions to spread their
own propaganda so it's not surprising
that many people yearn for the return of
the gatekeepers oh this hate and
violence is being facilitated by a
handful of Internet companies that
amount to the greatest propaganda
machine in history Congress demanded
that Facebook Twitter and Google do
something the gatekeepers tried to
reassert power Twitter and Google
punished users for violating their vague
and overly broad Terms of Service which
were partly exported to the US from more
sensorial jurisdictions things that
would be politically difficult and
perhaps unconstitutional or in some
cases certainly unconstitutional to
mandate here we don't have to even
consider because they get mandated in
Europe and then companies apply them
globally the medium is not something
neutral it does something to people it
takes hold of them it roughs them up it
massages them and bump them around but
if McLuhan is right there's no reverting
to the old days his technological
determinism will seem bleak to some but
his analysis also offers a path to
personal agency and self-awareness if
you take some violent and irritating
process say like radio or TV and start
looking at how it works what it's doing
to you and why it's doing it to you you
can get very enthralled very excited
what kind of media do you want not what
kind of press or set of journalists but
through what technological means do you
want to communicate and get information
if the 2010s were the decade of the
stream or the feed what if the 2020s
bring the return of the
content giants like Netflix and Disney
are in a mad scramble to lock their
copyright behind subscription paywalls
roughly reconstituting the branded TV
channels that cord cutters thought they
left behind but they're also part of a
consequential shift towards deriving
revenue from subscriptions instead of
advertising which generates a more
direct relationship between content
consumer and producer and we've already
begun to see dedicated encrypted
communication channels supplant public
timelines and further fracture mass
media following the habits of its users
even Facebook has pivoted hard away from
the newsfeed towards private groups and
chat could the revived channel with its
emphasis on personalization and constant
exchange signal the return of community
privacy and free thought in the 2020s or
will the 2020 see the continued erosion
of those values in which we turn our
major communications platforms into
public utilities heavily controlled by
the state if we begin to treat media
consumption as a personal responsibility
with awareness of how electric media
predisposes us to tribalism and opens
new pathways of manipulation we can
better opt-out resist and persuade
others to do the same if things go well
the next decade could present new
opportunities to spread ideas free of
needless gatekeeping and to carve out
more robust spaces physical and virtual
away from prying eyes and heavy hands
spaces where individualism free thought
and experimentation can flourish if not
society could be destabilized in 2020s
or perhaps we'll see a new more
pernicious form of gatekeeping like the
techno authoritarian control mechanisms
being developed in China in that
scenario the only recourse will be to
turn more urgently to state resistant
encryption tools and decentralized
Internet platforms a decentralized
framework where there isn't that
middleman that can be manipulated or
coerced or regulated into exposing your
data that's a better safer more
resilient world which doesn't end up in
this case where it's susceptible to
authoritarian
the future demands a greater commitment
to liberal tolerance of difference and
the fair and free exchange of ideas that
the coming decade with its opportunities
to leverage the tools that for so long
were out of reach for so many could and
should be a time of liberation choice
and prosperity rather than one of
collectivism control and misery